Sir, your misogyny is showing with the last line.
Women just aren't worth being with long term.
So I think right there
we can see maybe where part of the problem is originating.
I'm not even going to, um,
you know, go through the trouble of green screening your picture
and going through your account,
because I did, and I could have.
And like, ooh, um.
There are many self care techniques
that maybe you can take to make yourself more appealing.
You know, that's the answer that you men like to give us.
But more than that, a relationship is equal parts,
like work, doing things for each other,
you know, loving her in certain ways and helping around,
keeping up your own house.
Because if you lived in that house by yourself,
you would be doing 100% of the cleaning and cooking.
So nobody gives a fuck that you're holding your weight.
Okay,
and the fact that that's the thing you wanna cling to in this comment.
I cook some of the meals and I clean and I pay my part of the bills,
whether or not. Sounds like
maybe there's more to the problem than just carrying your weight.
Some of us would call that the actual bare minimum.
You're doing your fucking part,
living in the home that you also fucking live in.
Women are not complicated creatures.
It's really fucking common sense.
Don't be a fucking dick and your dick will get touched.